welcome to the show everybody we have
what what an eventful night we had last
night we have our first series of a
really important results for the 2022
midterms we had a number of different
primaries yesterday some of the results
are absolutely delightful and some of
the results are absolutely horrifying it
really runs the full gamut and we're
going to get to
all of it two races that we were
following very closely in pennsylvania
the senate race why the senate race in
pennsylvania the senate race in
pennsylvania could decide whether
democrats or republicans ultimately
control the senate starting in january
of 2023 and if it comes down to
pennsylvania
on the one hand we want to know who is
the republican nominee going to be
and on the other hand we also are
following whether trump's endorsements
continue to have value and memit oz was
the trump-endorsed candidate in the
republican pennsylvania senate primary
also
delightfully i was gleefully seeing the
results yesterday
that trumpist congressman madison
cawthorne lost his primary he's out he's
been in office 16 months and he has
already lost the primary and he is going
bye-bye so let's look at this one by one
starting with north carolina's 11th
district
chuck edwards a current republican state
senator in north carolina has defeated
the incumbent madison hawthorne now it
was close edward's coming in with just
over 33 percent of the vote cawthorne
losing with just under 32 percent of the
vote but it
nobody's saying it's so close we need a
recount for now nobody's talking about
fraud in fact madison cawthorne is
actually saying
that uh establishment forces in the
republican party turned against him
because he would criticize those who
needed criticism and all of this stuff
which we will get to but this is
absolutely fantastic news and we're
going to talk about that more in a
moment
on the pennsylvania side
uh starting with the democratic primary
john fetterman
almost literally from an operating room
easily winning the primary john
fetterman as we talked about on the
bonus show yesterday had a stroke over
the weekend ended up needing to have a
pacemaker with defibrillator installed
via surgery yesterday he's doing well he
easily won the reports are he will make
a full recovery and will be strongly
back on the campaign trail fetterman
will be facing the winner of the
republican primary and as of this moment
when we're taping today's show we don't
know who that is all night
trump endorsed republican mehmet oz was
losing losing to dave mccormick and as
the night went on oz chipped away
chipped away chipped away at the
advantage that mccormick had and by the
end of the night by this morning with 95
of the vote counted
mehmet oz is ahead by only 2 500 votes
that's 0.2 percent of the vote as a just
as a reminder
in pennsylvania if the margin of victory
is one half of one percent or less it
triggers an automatic recount these
numbers aren't final
but the point is if the numbers end up
being this close there will be an
automatic recount and we're off to the
races again and we will see ultimately
what the results of that are but we
don't
yet know because they are still counting
ballots now we're going to talk about
pennsylvania governor in a separate
segment it's a very important race and
it deserves its own time
uh but we will get to that in a moment
so madison cawthorne tweeting a
concession uh quote congratulations to
chuck edwards on securing the nomination
tonight it's time for the 11th district
republicans to rally behind the
republican ticket to defeat the
democrats november nominee this november
kawthorne did praise trump when
conceding take a look at this clip
oh you know what the thing that i love
about president trump is that when you
get your back pushed up against the wall
i've found that most people in politics
if it's not politically expedient to
them they'll turn your back on you in
the heartbeat
but no matter what you are facing when
donald trump has your back he has your
back to the end and that is why
i don't know that i really agree with
that i mean this was politically
expedient for trump to endorse cawthorne
at the end of the day
the guy running against cawthorne isn't
like a wild trumpist and kawthorne is a
wild trumpist so that's the political
expediency just before uh conceding
cawthorne did weigh in on the leaks of
his pictures and videos and all of this
stuff he says it's a coordinated strike
from within the republican party to take
him
there down been several photos and
videos of you circulating on online on
social media recently what can you say
to those constituents who maybe have
lost some confidence in you and and are
looking for some other kind of
leadership you know what i'll tell you
there's been a coordinated strength
carried out by really kind of the old
establishment wing of our party and it's
really something that i think is that
it's a loser's mentality they realize
the direction the country's going in the
direction that the population is going
in uh and if they want to be able to pay
off people from my past and try and
bring up old pictures or things that
happened years and years ago
i feel free to let them do that i think
the american people will see through
that well whatever i mean listen he's
right it was very clear that the
republican party uh establishment
decided we don't want madison cawthorn
to remain in the house of
representatives now his framing is
it won't matter because the country's
going in his direction he lost the
primary he is out and that's an
absolutely fantastic thing voters have
in a sense sent madison back to his room
to think about what he did cawthorne's
loss is also a loss for trump trump went
on troth central uh he he calls it truth
central as you might remember truth
essential it's actually called truth
social trump went on truth and endorsed
qathorn two nights ago and uh this one
did not go
trump's way so that is a loss for trump
now meanwhile this is just bizarre at
his event last night mehmet oz thanked
fox news propagandist sean hannity make
you proud
i want to thank sean hannity
sean's like a brother to me
when sean punches through something he
really punches through it he understands
exactly how to make a difference and
he's been doing that the same entire
campaign much of it behind the scenes
right giving me advice a late night
conversations again the kinds of things
that true friends do for each other
in another era in the american political
media landscape
it would be outrageous to hear
that
an on-air host on one of the major
networks was not only openly supporting
one of the candidates in a primary but
behind the scenes giving them advice and
pep talks at one point that would have
been that would have been seen as
inappropriate no no listen you have an
on-air persona
and it wouldn't it's not right for you
to be advising a candidate in this way
without it being really what you're
doing officially you you're
you're doing one thing and then you're
doing another thing behind the scenes
and you're attacking oz's opponent on
air without disclosing that you have
this sort of informal advisor to the
extent we know it's informal advisory
relationship at one point that would
have been outrageous
now we just kind of shrug and go yeah
hannity picked the candidate and was
helping memit oz and then on the other
hand dave mccormick who
we still don't know whether it will be
oz or mccormick almost in a in a tie at
this point 2 500 votes separating them
this you have to see
beyond parody mccormick now says
we might still win because of mail-in
ballots which of course the whole line
from the republican party has been
mail-in ballots are bad
mail-in ballots are fraud and now
mccormick is saying don't worry we've
still got the mail-in ballots coming
now we're gonna
we're gonna win this campaign we're
going to win this campaign
and uh and tomorrow right now we have
tens of thousands
of mail-in ballots that have not been
counted that are going to need to be
counted beginning tomorrow
and uh and so that unfortunately we're
not going to have resolution tonight
but we can see the path ahead we can see
victory ahead
don't worry guys the mail-in ballots my
party has uh attacked for the last uh
two years are what ultimately will save
us and this is normal for the right
whatever fits the narrative of the
current five minutes they go with so
those are some races great to see
madison cawthorne defeated that's bad
for trump now let's go to something that
is very very good for trump this is
genuinely scary
the pennsylvania gubernatorial race also
had its primary yesterday now on the
democratic side running unopposed is the
state's attorney general josh shapiro a
relatively unremarkable democrat
smart from everything i've seen
likeable
perfectly reasonable uncontroversial guy
just normal guy would be a normal
governor on the other side on the
republican side the winner of the uh
gubernatorial primary is a guy named
doug mastriano who pretty easily won
with a 24-point margin over the second
place candidate lou barletta doug
mastriano is an extraordinarily
dangerous weaponized conspiracy theorist
trumpist who was in washington dc at the
capitol on january 6th who has
promulgated so-called stop the steel
conspiracies
who has played coy with q and on
phraseology
and remember
that the governor appoints the secretary
of state the person in charge of running
pennsylvania's elections
uh this is really scary stuff really
really scary stuff
um two we have this interesting uh
report about masteriano two days before
the capitol riots mastriano said he was
heading to washington dc and calling out
to god for divine revelation he used
campaign funds to charter six buses to
shuttle followers to dc and told them he
would speak on the capitol steps around
one o'clock rioters broke into the
capitol some wielding bibles jesus 2020
signs and appeal to heaven flags and
shofars we'll get back to shofars on the
senate floor one insurrectionist called
out from the day is jesus christ we
invoke your name
and of course you know the rest of uh of
what happened on january 6. so this is a
wacky guy he was there for the stop the
steel rally ahead of the riots he tried
to conduct one of these arizona-style
partisan reviews of the election results
in pennsylvania he made debunked
conspiracy theory claims about the
election
a sort of centerpiece of his campaign in
pennsylvania he was going to speak at a
q anon branded con conference called
patriots arise in june of 21 ended up
not doing it because of the chaos in the
media that was generated from the news
that he would be speaking there and the
republicans know it's really big that
mastriano won rudy for example was
celebrating it posting i think this was
on truth social rudy giuliani writing
tonight the biggest win
is doug mastriano in pennsylvania he's a
veteran an historian and a true patriot
the most important quality in this
election is guts to destroy the democrat
express train to marxism and the rhinos
who enable it so the press will write
nice things about them doug will be to
pennsylvania what trump was for the
united states and he's not wrong they
are putting the insurrectionists inside
the house
um mastriano is disgusting here's one
wacky video back in um january
when masteriano announced he was running
they opened the event
with the blowing of a shofar now i don't
know how many of you know what a shofar
is a shofar is a ram's horn it's an
element of the jewish faith and it's
used uh to signify sometimes the sabbath
uh sometimes the end of the fasting
period at yom kippur and there's
actually a history of masteriano
misusing
jewish symbols this was the start of the
campaign from austriano this people
i believe god
is about
to manifest himself brother
he has to because we cannot keep going
the way we're going
amen
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
okay
so uh masteriano is not jewish and he
has this history of misusing jewish
symbols as campaign props back in april
he spoke and raised money at a far-right
christian conference called patriots
arise for god and country
and they promoted conspiracy theories
including
the existence of a global cabal of sex
trafficking democrats you guys have
heard this stuff before 911 was a false
flag vaccines are genocide therapy adolf
hitler faked his death
and once again jewish organizations
criticized that
for the improper use of campaign props
they also used a shofar there so this is
a disgusting guy and he's a dangerous
guy
the 2024 election
could come down to pennsylvania and if
doug mastriano gets to decide who runs
that election it's a really really bad
thing so pennsylvania is becoming a
major area of focus
we should support josh shapiro for
governor we should support john
fetterman for senator now the good news
is for now that recently democrats tend
to win the governorship in pennsylvania
so if we look at some recent elections
in 2018 the democrat tom wolf won easily
by 17 points in 2014 the democrat tom
wolf won easily by about nine points in
2010 a republican did win tom corbett
won by about nine points but then in 20
2006 ed rendell
ran away with it with a 21-point win so
the hope is
that it's just an overwhelming
democratic gubernatorial victory in
pennsylvania if not
we're really up for it and there's many
different important races
months ago we said pennsylvania will be
a focus pennsylvania's gubernatorial
race is quite literally a referendum on
democracy this is as big as any other
issue just
do you support a democratic system and
if you do
you've got to vote for josh shapiro and
if people are looking to phone bank in a
particular race that is a race that is
of significant interest meanwhile one
bit of good gubernatorial news from
yesterday
far
idaho gubernatorial candidate janice
mcgeechen
uh maybe it's pronounced mcgeeken i
don't know
she lost in idaho and that is a very
good thing so initial results a mixed
bag
many more primaries coming next tuesday
six days from today and of course we'll
be covering all of it live and just a
quick reminder monday memorial day we're
doing a one-day membership special we
are blowing members we might run out of
memberships okay we are going to offer
an incredible discount off of
memberships on our website our primary
funding source on monday memorial day if
you want to be notified of how to get
the discounted membership just get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right let's take a little bit of a
dive into the deep end of the pool of
hypocrisy i know hypocrisy doesn't
matter on the american right anymore i
know that they will say anything
and then say the opposite if it becomes
politically convenient to make a
different claim i know i'm i'm very much
aware of that but this is sort of a new
low
some of you may be familiar with
republican congressman dan crenshaw dan
crenshaw is a military veteran and while
he was in the military due to an injury
he lost an eye and he wears an eye patch
over one eye
dan crenshaw's political ideas are
absolutely terrible i find his views on
almost every political issue disgusting
but we don't make fun of him for having
lost an eye that doesn't make any sense
that's vile that's gross
well this weekend i'm sorry not this
weekend earlier this week no it was this
weekend uh tucker carlson referred to
congressman dan crenshaw as i patch
mccain ridiculing his physical
appearance as a result of the fact that
he lost an eye through military service
military service which tucker carlson of
course has never done
notably tucker said this while he was
interviewing uh former congresswoman
tulsi gabbard who also is a military
veteran uh listen to what tucker carlson
had to say if you're watching check out
the sort of non-reaction from tool c the
more i think about it takes a lot of
gall for eye patch mccain to attack moms
who worry about baby formula as quote
pro russia i mean that's probably one
that's one of the most outrageous things
i think i've ever heard now that i'm
thinking about i mean why not just
answer the question why why the attacks
what does that tell you eye patch mccain
eye patch
well it turns out that this is not just
generally a contradiction of tucker's
typical view of we respect the military
and people who have served the country
and all this different stuff tucker has
actually specifically attacked people in
the past
for making fun of dan crenshaw's eye
patch we have video of this the the guys
over at midas touch
actually made it a side-by-side and on
the left of your screen you're going to
see what tucker had to say back in
november of 2018. in november of 2018
comedian pete davidson
uh kind of made fun of uh dan crenshaw's
eye patch
and tucker attacked him and then on the
right you will again see what tucker
said over the weekend take a look at
this texas congressional candidate dan
crenshaw lost an eye to an ied in
afghanistan on saturday actor pete
davidson mocked him as one of the quote
really gross people running for office
this year oh my god he said
added i'm sorry i know he lost his eye
in war or whatever
now understand that even in saying that
pete davidson isn't even really making
fun of the eye patch
pete davidson was saying
dan crenshaw is a disgusting political
candidate and he's like i know he lost
an eye in war or whatever sure the or
whatever is callous but he's not even
really making fun of the fact that he
wears an eye patch he's just saying
eye patch aside i find him to be a
disgusting candidate and tucker thought
that that was offensive and said it was
inappropriate and then again here's
tucker on it was indeed monday night
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know the more i think about it it
takes a lot of gall for eye patch mccain
to attack moms who worry about baby
formula as quote pro russia what a guy
huh what a guy it's actually much worse
for tucker to do this than pete davidson
to be perfectly frank like aside from
the point that pete davidson wasn't even
really making fun of it he was just a
little bit dismissive of okay i mean he
lost an eye in war or whatever but he's
still a bad candidate kalas but but not
making fun of it it's worse for tucker
to do this because tucker knows dan
crenshaw's story he knows dan crenshaw's
biography he knows exactly how dan
crenshaw lost his eye and i think at the
time at least pete davidson had a very
limited understanding of dan crenshaw's
situation but i i know you know this
pointing out hypocrisy no longer has an
impact when we are up against people
whose view is win at all costs attack
the other side at all costs even for
things that we do
when that's their approach when that's
their perspective this type of hypocrisy
doesn't actually matter making fun of
dan crenshaw's eye patch used to be a
terrible sin when pete davidson did it
but now it's fine because crenshaw said
something tucker carlson didn't like and
tulsi gabbard also didn't like what dan
crenshaw said
and and again
i'm not defending crenshaw as a
politician crenshaw's horrible his
policy ideas are terrible he spreads all
sorts of disinformation about economics
and what he believes socialism to be
we've done a ton you know maybe five six
different clips debunking the things
crenshaw has said
but
these are the people that supposedly
respect the troops support the troops
honor military service i patch mccain
and by the way mccain i can only assume
that tucker
is maybe
seeing crenshaw as in the line of the
late senator john mccain which i can
only imagine and infer
is also not great as far as tucker is
concerned i don't know we know that late
in his life john mccain had some kind of
departures from some elements of the
republican party it's all vile it's all
gross and his viewers will never ever
ever hold them accountable for it i want
to tell everybody something about your
cable subscription that you may not know
now i'm not telling you what to do here
i'm not even sure what to do and i'll
tell you why this is a double-edged
sword but it's important that everybody
know
that if you have a cable tv subscription
with any of the major cable providers
you are paying fox news you are keeping
fox news afloat now it's a little bit
different when i say that you are
keeping fox news afloat than saying you
are keeping hgtv afloat or whatever the
case may be why is it different the
difference is that fox news specifically
mostly has deals with the large cable
providers that for each subscriber
they get a significant amount of revenue
typically almost two bucks a month so if
you have a cable subscription normal
cable subscription you never watch fox
news
you probably unbeknownst to you are
still sending fox news specifically
close to two dollars a month or close to
20 bucks per year now as we've said
before
fox news we've been talking about it all
week
numerous fox news hosts have been
perpetuating these ideas of so-called
great replacement theory or white
replacement theory it goes by both names
this was one of the undergirding
foundations of the buffalo shooters
manifesto and the buffalo shooter's
motivation for going out and seeking
black people to kill
okay
there's lots of other platforms that are
promoting this stuff as well the
difference is many of those other ones
are online so like for example some of
the people promoting white replacement
theory are on youtube and they make
money with ad revenue if you don't watch
them on youtube you're not giving them
any money great
the difference is that with your cable
subscription
even if you don't watch fox news you're
still giving them in many cases close to
two bucks a month now there's a website
i encourage you to check out called
unfoxmycablebox.com
and it number one tells you the full
scope of how fox news is funded in this
way and number two it allows you to tell
your cable provider to separate out fox
news to make it an optional channel on
just about every cable system you can't
say i don't want fox if you don't want
to pay for hbo on every cable system
that i'm aware of you just say i don't
want hbo great you don't get hbo and you
don't pay for hbo on most cable systems
you can't remove fox news and fox
business okay if you pay for for cable
or satellite tv you are subsidizing fox
news whether you watch it or not
the uh
uh the cable provider pays fox and they
pass the cost directly to you now we've
said before i've explained to you fox
doesn't depend that much on ad revenue
why not
because of these monthly fees from
subscribers when all of those
advertisers bailed on tucker carlson's
show
and we watched an episode and we saw
that he had almost no advertisers left
and the advertisers he had left were
sort of like
low rent low low value kind of low brow
advertisers the mic pillows of the world
and stuff like that we laughed about it
and we had a grand old time but we
acknowledged that it doesn't really
matter that much because fox news's
revenue model two-thirds comes from
subscriber fees through cable providers
fox news makes close to two billion
dollars a year
from these hidden subscriber fees that's
twice what cnn makes and it's three
times as much as msnbc makes so sadly
all of our money if we have cable is
being used to fund this extremist
programming you should not be forced to
subsidize fox news but you don't have a
choice if you have a cable subscription
so check out unfox my cable box read
about it fill it out which will send a
message to your cable provider telling
them separate this out a lot allow me to
say no and that's what we really have to
do i mean obviously we can also cut the
cord
the sad part about cutting the cord
while many people have done it and i
don't have any moral opposition to it
we we recently learned that thanks to
cord cutting c-span which is a very
valuable service which has no ad revenue
c-span has been significantly hurt by
cost cutting so that's the tragic thing
you might say well i'll cut the cord to
stop funding fox great but then you also
end up hurting c-span which we don't
want to hurt c-span provides a valuable
public service so we have to pressure
the cable and satellite providers to
stop
including fox news by default
you should be able to say i don't want
fox and if you don't want fox you
shouldn't have to pay for fox and the
cable provider shouldn't have to pay for
fox regardless that's the sort of system
that needs to be upended we're going to
keep you updated there's currently
negotiations actually happening right
now fox and cable providers are
negotiating their next contracts on this
on these subscriber fees and
we could really kneecap fox news it's
not not a limitation on speech anybody
who wants to fund fox should be able to
anybody who wants to watch it should be
able to nobody should be silencing fox
fox can do whatever they want but
we shouldn't by default be paying for
fox news when we certainly don't watch
it and absolutely don't want to be
funding it we'll have more on this on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show we're
going to look at how a conspiracy theory
gets oxygen and grows and grows and it
can very be very quickly become so big
that even finding out it's not true
won't debunk it for the people
perpetuating it wait what am i what am i
talking about i'm going to show you i'm
going to show you the genesis of a
conspiracy some might say the oranges of
a conspiracy for lack of a better term
we're going to look at an interview on
the joe rogan podcast with a guy who is
he he goes by the name hotep jesus i
guess his name is brian sharp but he
goes by hotep jesus
himself a spreader of conspiracy
theories of all kinds hotep jesus has
previously said that the atlantic slave
trade was a myth that the vast majority
of african americans are the original
native americans and many other
conspiracy theories okay hotep jesus
appears on the joe rogan program
and joe rogan brings up
the the widely debunked claim that
australia was going to pass a law
to ban anybody from growing their own
food you you know how i grow my radishes
and my cukes and my zooks in the
backyard all of that stuff
the the claim from rogan is in australia
that would be against the law now it's
not true we're going to look at the clip
and i want you to really look at first
how long they spend talking about how
terrible it is that australia is doing
this until they get the idea to look for
an article
they can't find any articles and then
rogan goes oh man it might not be a real
story but then hotep jesus says
even if it's fake
the fact that you thought it is probably
a warning that they're going to do it at
some point
and this is the epitome of
not finding evidence
fuels us believing it's probably true
because maybe the evidence is being
hidden that this is a genius and genius
in a terrible way clinic on
conspiratorial thinking and they spent a
bunch of this episode
slamming so-called fake news
and then they fell for it and they
perpetuated it take a look at this you
know i want to find out what this is but
i read something briefly and i didn't
get into the article but they were
saying that they were trying to pass a
bill that would outlaw you growing your
own food in australia oh my god
did you read that no it was a part of
australia i think it was new south wales
okay someone's trying to pass a law that
won't allow you to grow your own food
and they were saying well you could grow
your own food and what else the disease
was from your food so now rogan is
ridiculing
the things that the people
saying growing your own food is bad
supposedly said but the whole story is
fake now they're ridiculing imaginary
people it affects the population kills
us all oh we can't have that because
they pulled that car i want to know what
what their justification was but i'm
pretty sure it had to do with like
agricultural contamination or you know
like i mean you could justify it if
you're a real piece of [ __ ] you could
say well you know most pandemics have
come from agriculture
animal agriculture we can have unchecked
pig ownership
that's not fair we can you be growing
vegetables what have your vegetables
ever got in them and diseases
[Laughter]
[ __ ] creeps man these [ __ ] creeps
they they got a good grip on people
during the pandemic they locked their
way down in australia and then you know
what we're going to stop these
[ __ ] from rolling their own
food because that's how you smoke out an
anti-vaxxer and look at now now the
story is fake and it's now being built
up into this is part of the control
you tell people you go crazy in
australia with covid you tell people
they can't go to the grocery store and
they can't grow their own food in order
to force anti-vaxxers to go and get
themselves vaccinated because otherwise
they'll starve it's a three-layer
conspiracy theory now all based on
nothing and now is when it starts to
turn and they go maybe we should find
some evidence that this actually is
happening
make you can't even go go to the grocery
store anymore and you can't grow your
food no dependent take that shot [ __ ]
do you find anything you are now
dependent upon
passes bill
i mean i know what to look for i'm just
it's not nothing's coming up uh the
closest thing i could find was something
like this i don't that's not food no
it's not it's not new zealand it's in uh
it's in australia i know but this is
close new zealand is like right around
the corner could have right um doesn't
matter that rogan's talking about
australia if they find it in new zealand
it's close enough but it's not there
either ah it's got to be a real thing it
seems too good to not be it's it's
obviously um
outlaw growing food in australia and
nothing not a single thing comes up
uh-oh
hold on except for that which was a
false thing
growing your own food they want they
want us
completely
dependent
so hotep now he's unfazed by the fact
that there's no evidence of the story
he's like this this is part of them
wanting us dependent
yeah i can't find it either damn it
it better not be fake
it might be fake
but
even if it's fake right like the fake is
usually the warning
[Music]
even if it's fake the fake is usually
the warning that's like the
that's the epitome of these people if
they had found an article saying this
was happening in australia the article
would be the proof
they didn't find the article
so it was a fake story
now that's the proof it's probably
coming because the fake stories usually
come before it becomes a real story it's
the warning
this is unbelievable and almost three
minutes half of which is just building
on
they don't want to let you grow their
own food well that's not true the reason
they don't want to do it is to smoke out
anti-vaxxers to force them to go and get
vaccinated by making them unable to grow
their own food and not letting them go
to grocery stores unless they're
vaccinated so that's layer number three
layer number three this is part of the
general they want to control you and
they want you to be dependent oh it
turns out it's not real oh well it
doesn't matter it's probably the fact
that you thought it was
is a sign that at some point it will be
and one of the most brilliant things is
as rogan starts to realize it's fake
the guest doesn't care and hotep jesus
is like filling the dead air by saying
they want us dependent
they want to control us
he's not even reacting to the fact that
there's no story he just keeps going
filling the dead air and it hits all the
points of conspiratorial thinking
including that the absence of evidence
rogan thought it they find no evidence
that's part of the conspiracy that's
probably a sign that it's coming it is
textbook clinic on this stuff and by the
way they almost seem disappointed that
it's not true
it would be terrible if you weren't
allowed to grow your own food they
should be overjoyed oh my god what great
news you can grow your own food in
australia you can do it they're not
overjoyed they're almost like bummed out
that the story's not real unbelievable
stuff
scary
and probably a bunch of people still
came away from that believing that it's
true that australia won't let you grow
your own food scary stuff
hey this is a very strange series of
events um
earlier in the day on um
monday
jordan peterson attacked me
he subsequently went on to call a woman
ugly
and then announced he's quitting twitter
because it's all gotten too out of
control he's told his staff to change
his password and not give him access to
it however multiple tweets continue to
be posted after that presumably by his
staff so let's go kind of like point by
point here okay so the first thing that
happened is that jordan peterson posted
about my video criticizing him jordan
peterson recently gave a talk
during which he wept because young
people are being told that there's a
climate crisis
and jordan peterson didn't like my video
and he tweeted at me he attacked me and
he said quote i was speaking of the
unacceptable demoralization of young
people
i've seen it all over the world and this
cynical dismissal is all you can muster
how utterly pathetic deepakman how do
you think endless apocalyptic
catastrophizing affects children
he then went on
uh to send an additional tweet he sent a
second tweet very quickly
where he said and congratulations on
capturing an audience motivated to spew
so consistently the corrosive and
personal vitriol that makes up the
comments on this video clip a likely
epitaph for you eaten by his own
children so he's really really really
not happy with me
now as a reminder the video he's
referring to is jordan peterson weeps
over climate activism and in that video
i pointed out
we shouldn't be weeping
that it's upsetting to kids to learn
about what we're doing to the planet we
should be weeping over the fact that
we're destroying the planet and jordan
peterson's perspective is when you tell
children and young people
all of these terrible things that are
going on it's demoralizing to them it's
horrible and he wept he wept he wept
over it and my point was we have to be
honest with people and if we're bringing
up a new generation who is number one
going to deal with the consequences of
climate change and number two be in a
position hopefully to deal with it we
can't lie to them we can't hide from
them that this is what's happening on
this planet and anyway he didn't like it
he thinks it's demoralizing to tell them
that so jordan peterson flipping out on
me
moments later
he um went after the physical appearance
of a woman
um there is this woman i actually
haven't been following this story but i
guess the sports illustrated swimsuit
issue this year
wanted to feature
different body types and there's a
heavier woman who was featured and
jordan peterson after attacking me on
twitter tweeted about this woman sorry
not beautiful and no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is going to
change that so kind of a weird thing for
jordan peterson to be tweeting about and
then not too long after that jordan
peterson announced that he is indeed
leaving twitter uh it's gotten to be too
much for him saying quote so i told my
staff to change my password to keep me
from temptation and am departing once
again if i have something to say i'll
write an article or make a video if the
issue is not important enough to justify
that then perhaps it would be best to
just let it go
very very unstable incredibly unstable
individual and uh honestly i don't even
i mean listen jordan peterson
we've talked for a while about how he
seems unwell we've talked for a while
about how a lot of his followers seem to
be sort of like bamboozled and fall into
a cult of personality we've said a lot
of things about jordan peterson i'm
actually with him
significant use of twitter isn't that
healthy we know that and for some people
in particular it's really not healthy i
know people personally who because of
their personalities
uh addictive personalities and and sort
of uh
the the endless need to keep scrolling
i see how corrosive it is to their um uh
mental state their emotional state to be
on social media they just shouldn't be
on it and it really seems like for
jordan peterson it's very bad to be on
social media so i actually respect him
for getting off of twitter
it's not clear he's really off because
the tweets keep coming but i guess it's
his staff that are sending the tweets
but what a 24 hours flipping out on me
calling a woman ugly
and then saying it's gotten bad and i'm
quitting so we wish him the best
i think it is better for him not to be
on twitter
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right i'm coming to you for help on
this i need people's opinions um about
ten days ago
we received a call when we were taking
live calls
from uh someone who claimed to be a
pro-trump individual who was formerly a
moderator on what's called the donald
the donald was a subreddit on the
website reddit that was so toxically
pro-trump and spreading so much
disinformation and so problematic that
it was ultimately banned by reddit so
this guy calls in and says hey
i used to be a moderator on the donald
and the guy spread even on this program
disinformation about ivermectin and
mysoprostol and okay we already talked
about that
i didn't think much more about it but in
the time that uh followed
the um release of that clip i started
getting messages from people
saying hey david we think that that guy
who called is ron watkins and wrote in
and ann said hi david love your show
thank you for the quality work you do
i just had to share that the recent
caller who said he was a moderator for
the donald or whatever it's called to me
his voice sounds like ron watkins just
wondering and then another viewer wrote
in evan who said the donald equals ron
watkins hey david love the show as my
sister says after i shared a few videos
he is so astute and cute too okay i just
listened to the new upload regarding
tricked by a trumpist the caller sounds
just like ron watkins the alleged 4chan
cuanon leader and also the guy running
for arizona's congressional second
district could this be the same guy
and i have to tell you i went back and
listened to it
and there's definitely a similarity
let's listen to the voice this is ron
watkins during a recent debate this is
the q anon guy running in arizona he
made that really strange opening
statement listen to his voice here and i
will make sure that your rights are
are kept
thank you okay
here's one more clip ron watkins listen
to the voice ron some people say that a
lot of this was stoked by q anon what is
your relationship with q a not i have no
relationship with q anon none at all not
at all um the reports are that your
bulletin board sites hosted postings
that launched and launched a q a on
conspiracy so i ran a free speech
website and i was the administrator
and there were many thousands of
thousands of people that posted on those
sites uh q was just one of those and i
do not know who it was and i'm not that
okay so that that's the voice of ron
watkins
now let's listen to the voice of the guy
who called me all right tell me if you
think this is the same person let's go
next to uh let's go to rich from
illinois rich welcome
hi david hello
um so that was the top mod of the donald
on reddit for years until just before it
was banned and with elon buying twitter
do you think that there will be a
general shift in policy
for the uh the tech places
towards allowing things
like medical misinformation
there's definitely a similarity the guy
said his name is rich rather than ron
okay
i guess you could give a different name
what do you think is it possible that
this is the same guy it's a very
interesting question and multiple people
wondering let's listen to a little bit
more such as ivermectin and what
vice's motherboard did yesterday with uh
tweeting out the misoprostol for
abortion pills
i don't know guys that it is very very
interesting there is absolutely some
kind of similarity but
first of all
in the middle of a congressional
campaign i don't know why ron watkins
would be calling this show
secondly i don't know why he would use
the name rich i don't know i mean maybe
he would maybe there's a good reason why
he would maybe it's logical that he
would because he's running a
congressional campaign
but it is very interesting and that call
generating so much content and now
people saying it sounds like the q guy
so let me know what you think i don't
have any other particular information
about it but it is certainly very
interesting
i want to look at a clip with you today
of uh this christian hate preacher
greg locke okay
this is a guy we've talked about before
there's a church called the global
vision bible church in uh tennessee
i looked to see if they are actually a
tax-exempt church
and i was not able to definitively find
out one way or the other as many of you
know churches
quote real churches are able to be tax
exempt in the united states this allows
them to not pay property tax this allows
them a lot of other tax benefits and one
of the rules is they're not allowed to
do politics at the pulpit you can't be a
political organization and have tax
exempt status i'm going to play a wild
clip for you here from global vision
bible church this is greg locke
he uh threatens democrats that are
watching him
he threatens an insurrection he says
that nobody in his church should be
voting for democrats this is the epitome
of why there should not be tax-exempt
status for the religious wing of
churches if you run a school a church
school
a church-based school
and you're teaching real curriculum i'm
actually okay with the educational side
of a church having tax exemption
but this sort of stuff has to end take a
listen to this
i'm to the place right now if you vote
democrat i don't even want you around
this church you can get out okay so
right off the bat saying democrats
aren't welcome here
that's a pretty political statement
you get out you demon
you can get out you baby butchering
election thief
so that by the way baby butchering
that's talking about abortion so this is
all politics this is exactly the stuff
churches aren't allowed to do if they
want to maintain tax-exempt status how
many billions of dollars
are being uh
subsidized by random taxpayers because
churches don't pay taxes but still do
politics you cannot be a christian and
vote democrat in this nation i don't
care how mad that makes you you get
pissed off as you want to you cannot be
a christian and vote democrat in this
nation they are god denying demons that
butcher babies and hate this nation
they hate this nation
get mad all you want to
i don't care if you stand i don't care
if you throw tomatoes praise god i'm
about to throw a microphone up in his
house
right cnn can eat my dirty socks you
cannot be a democrat and a christian you
cannot somebody say amen
i actually don't remember we once had a
video of a pastor that ate dog poop on
stage to prove some kind of point
i don't remember if it was this guy let
me see greg lock eating dog poop
um
i think it was okay let's continue
anyway the rest of you get out
get out
get out in the name of jesus
i ain't playing your stupid games
bunch of devils
i'm sick of it
they won't talk about the insurrection
um
let me tell you something
you ain't seen the insurrection yet
whoa
you keep on pushing our buttons you low
down sorry compromisers
you god hating communist america you'll
find out what the insurrection is cause
we ain't playing your garbage we ain't
so now threatening violence threatening
something even saying the the so-called
insurrection of january 6
that ain't nothing compared to the
insurrection they might do
play in your mess my bible says that the
church of the living god is an
institution that the gates of hell shall
not prevail against it and the bible
says that we'll take it by force that's
what the bible says
that's what the bible says
imagine thinking that this nonsense has
anything to do with the teachings of
jesus like i i'm not a christian so i
don't care about the teachings of jesus
they have no impact on my life
whatsoever but i know people who
actually care about the teachings of
jesus insofar as how to treat other
people and feeding the poor and being a
good neighbor and all these different
things
this has nothing to do with the
teachings of jesus and the idea that
this is a so-called christian church is
absolutely bonkers now again on the
tax-exempt status this is global vision
bible church in tennessee there's
another church by a similar name in
california which is tax exempt that's
not this church i looked for the 501c3
status and and number non-profit number
for this church i wasn't able to find
one now that doesn't really mean
anything very often these churches even
though it's called global vision bible
church it might in reality be called
something like you know one two three
four five ministries llc and i i just
don't know it so that that's a very
common thing that the actual filing name
is different than the doing business as
but at this point
at minimum there should be an
investigation due to the very brazen
calls for violence and number two
if they are tax exempt he is literally
saying democrats get out
if you don't allow democrats in your
church you're doing politics and you
shouldn't be a tax-exempt institution
horrifying and i don't have the number
in front of me but i've previously told
you
billions of dollars a year
go in the form of tax exemptions
to churches many of which do political
advocacy advocacy which they should not
be doing
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192
david p
um here is a caller
thrilled that madison cothorn lost i
have to tell you i also am thrilled
about it
hey david it's dylan from north carolina
i'm just letting you know that i love
the show baby you do a great job you do
some great coverage yes sir yes sir and
also uh i really just want to say that
uh i'd like to rejoice in the fact that
madison hawthorne is no longer in the
[ __ ] house get that [ __ ] out of
here baby love you david take care thank
you so much for the call yeah it is i
mean listen we
i get it the guy who beat madison
cawthorne is almost certainly going to
be the winner in that district
and it will stay with a republican it's
not like madison cawthorne is being
replaced with a reasonable democrat or a
progressive
but because cawthorne is emblematic of
the debasement of american politics
where a completely incompetent clown
with no no business being involved in
politics
wins thanks to the combination of riding
trump's coattails and the mega wave of
the 2020 well yeah all this different
stuff
it is still a good thing to see him lose
and see him removed we'll then have to
you know deal with the fact that the guy
who replaces him will probably be 80 as
bad
uh but it's okay to be happy about it
i'm happy madison cawthorne lost he had
no business being there and
unfortunately i don't know that we're
going to be as successful in making some
of some of these other maga people a
one-term members of congress we're going
to try don't get me wrong we're going to
try
but i don't know that it will be
successful let's just be happy that he
lost at least for the next day
we are going to talk on the bonus show
today uh and this is that same bonus
show that alex jones has been talking
about the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad yeah
that's the one i'm talking about a
lawsuit is now seeking more than two
million dollars in damages from
the fake republican electors in
wisconsin this would be
beautiful beautiful if it succeeded
number two the fda is announcing some
plans to ease the shortage of baby
formula which is becoming an area of
major concern
parents just worried am i going to have
the formula to feed my kid
and thirdly a judge strikes down
tennessee's transgender bathroom sign
law this is this is a genuinely
interesting case and it has to do with a
lot of different things going on at the
federal level and at the state level and
elsewhere so we're going to talk about
that on today's bonus show as well if
you want to get access to the bonus show
today
very easy sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code obama to get
a discount if you'd rather get the big
discount on memorial day fine fine with
me it's only 12 days away
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then monday morning monday memorial
day you'll get an email in which i will
tell you how to take advantage of this
great membership discount so no no shame
in waiting until memorial day we will
see you on the bonus show or otherwise
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new
show